action you've never seen
races across your screen as you thrill
to a new dimension in picture making
carnival of souls
this is the shocking story of a crew
crawl from the river to race through a
nightmare walking a tightrope between
heaven and hell
from the unreal she crashes through to
reality
but try she will to lead a normal life
she is torn from a gold
there's no privacy in a knife she's ever
watched tormented
either it's her neighbor desirous of her
physically watching her with his
layering eye
or it's the evil eye of the man the man
who taunts her the man who wants it from
the bottom of the river they come
they reach for her
they demand that she dance with them at
the carnival of souls
she is a girl-driven mad by the
relentless forces of the beyond
he will not relent as he comes for her
again and again
she whirls between the real and the
unreal trying to cling to life
i like being with you really i do
i don't want to be alone tonight
i want to be near you
honey
you don't want to go in there all by
yourself do you
but she must watch herself in death
she must dance at the carnival of souls
held just for her
for they have come for her for the last
time
claiming her as one of their own
carnival of souls arouses such emotion
that the management has been forced to
state positively no refunds
carnival of souls is the shocker of all
time guaranteed to sweep you into a new
dimension of picture making